all right airlines are focusing on what
they can do to make flying easier as air
travel becomes increasingly difficult
for passengers one consumer survey says
Delta Airlines is ranked second in North
America among traditional carriers the
atlanta-based airline flies to 334
destinations in 62 countries Delta
offers more than 15,000 flights every
day it carries more than 180 million
passengers a year
CEO bastion join Delta in 1990 in 1998
he took over as chief executive officer
in May last year his leadership
philosophy is this taking care of our
people in an interview you will see only
on CBS this morning
Bastion will tell us about Delta's new
free in-flight messaging service it will
allow passengers to use iMessage
whatsapp and Facebook messenger own
Wi-Fi enabled flights and we're pleased
to have him welcome thank you great
great to have you at this table we want
to talk about the new service right
moment but Porto Rico everybody is
concerned about how can Delta help more
because you know something about
transportation right to get supplies
there to help the people of Puerto Rico
well first of all our prayers and
thoughts go out to the people
Puerto Rico is just a devastating
devastating situation we do fly to
Puerto Rico we've got a number of
flights the problem right now is the
infrastructure in terms of getting in
there was only a couple days ago before
we were even allowed to fly on the
island and so the airport's don't have
power you need to were still restricted
I think today we're gonna try to get
three flights in but that's the maximum
we would we would take everything we
could fly we'd fly 747s if we could
problem is the infrastructure when you
land is not sustainable and whatnot so
there's only so much they can do to in
terms of the short term relief some have
suggested would be helpful if the US
military could go in there because
they've got hospital ships and they've
got all kinds of things that are
something generating yeah yeah III
completely completely agree that the
other issue though is people need to get
out and some people need to get in and
so transporting people so then the only
people were taken right now our
humanitarian people so we're so
customers are trying to find ways to get
to the island it's just not unfortunates
just not possible
really tell you you're doing all you can
is doing everything we can in which we
could do more yes sir you're pleased
with how your company because they have
a lot of unhappy people at the airport
everybody as you know it has something
to say about how it's going or not going
yeah no absolutely it's it's it's it's
truly just a situation with the physical
limitations and I just Delta all the
neurons I think we'd all love to to be
able to fly more witches can't we've
capped our fares there's no there's no
pricing to be made out of this this is
not it's the customer that's not never
never never well let's talk about your
new service that you're offering
yeah it's texting an air right we like
this you know how'd this come about well
you know we're in the business of
connecting people connecting the world
and we want our customers while they're
flying to stay connected to their homes
to their friends in flying so we've
we've developed together with our
partners at gogo a free messaging app so
that we that part again a free Mary
messaging for text messaging so starting
this weekend any flight you're on and
Delta anywhere in the world you will
have the ability to text for free really
around the world around the world like
when you get Wi-Fi sometimes you have to
pay for the extra the gogo in-flight so
this is you don't have to pay know there
you'll just access the app that's on the
plane itself you don't actually have to
pay to get on with respect to Wi-Fi and
messaging will be for free does that
mean you're gonna allow cell phone
service to never really say never never
in my lifetime yeah please I assume that
goodness have a lot of people who want
Wi-Fi and want the capacity message does
that hold true in terms of surveys you
take yeah it is a important feature for
people traveling people want Wi-Fi the
problem we have is the bandwidth still
isn't strong enough the Cape the
satellite bandwidth so we're still
working on upgrading the bandwidth we've
got about 200 of our latest planes in
the newest to kayuu bandwidth that
allows for free usage they're not for
users but you access across the entire
plane the the cost in my perspective
should come down to you know just kind
of what a cost to be on the ground here
so maybe if it's it's nominal or a small
uptick today we still have to charge too
much because of the quality is not there
yet but will eventually get to a point
where there's free service in the air
and you'll have ubiquitous service and
city on the cabin while you're there as
well some people like me who are tall
6-3 worried about putting more people in
the same space and shortening the space
between seats yes yeah I would like to
speak to that too because butts in this
country are getting bigger I'll speak
for myself on that I hope you have no
plans to shrink the size of the seats or
to Charlie's point to do anything with
the legroom to that we say what speak
into the microphone what's it like I'm 6
foot 3 myself Charlie we are not
changing legroom we haven't changed it
in years what we're doing is we're
getting bigger planes and better planes
the 321 is the 737s our newest plane is
the Airbus 350 our seat sizes this is
standard in fact though the the newest
states were bringing in which is the C
Series our smaller domestic planes
actually have a larger seat size when
you when you travel you sit in the back
of the plane why I sit in the back many
times because I want our customers that
have the higher value tickets to be able
to sit up front or are more loyal
customers to sit up front and I also
want to see how the product is do they
know it's you
absolutely video it's kind of hard to
avoid did I read that you're getting rid
of 747s yeah we're retiring meds at the
end of this year so what happens when a
plane is retired why does it go that
plane goes to the desert and gets
chopped up is that right yeah yeah it's
a it's a it's a plane that's too
expensive the fly it's got four engines
it's old technology it's a great it was
a great airplane in fact we have the
very first one we took in our museum now
in Atlanta it's the only one that wants
to go visit it's a great great museum
item to go see but it's the newest
technology the 350 has two engines it's
it's got a beautiful beautiful interior
in fact we won the cabin of the year for
our newest Airbus 350 of the business
cabin with a sliding door in fact and
this is a business cabin not first so
it's a great product and we're excited
about bringing that to market thank you
we got to go but before we do and I just
have to say a heartfelt thank you I fly
Delta all the time but Delta flew the
last flight out of Fort Myers that got
my mom and a hunt my mother-in-law 180
people and their dogs and pets out
before irma struck and I'm telling that
Delta was the only one flying in that
day thank you thank you I appreciate it
really
our PR people did
and our people took 10,000 people out in
the last day out of South Florida and
out of the islands including Puerto Rico
and we just wish we got more if somebody
wants it doing good is good business
it's absolutely it's the right thing to
do that's our motto thanks ed thanks
Rodney nice to have you here